I have a in the chairman's office
down the hall to photographs,
uh, one is, uh,
of the English department
in 1924 and there are, um,
uh, the number of distinguished
gentlemen casually posed in it.
Uh, you, you distinguished
scholars, uh, but all gentlemen,
uh, and combine and take
a look at it sometime.
I also have a photograph from 1967
in which there are more distinguished
gentleman, uh, less casually
posed. In fact, a raid, uh, in a,
um, uh, you know, sort
of Phalynx, uh, and, uh,
seated in the middle of
these men is one woman,
uh, marine bore off. Uh, Marie, uh,
is our guest lecturer today and
I'm delighted to have her here.
She has been a member of this English
department and a distinguished member of
this English department for a long time.
Um,
she is a medievalist,
uh,
a scholar of modern poetry,
a translator of Middle
English poetry poet herself.
Uh, and she views, um,
poetry or you, you Marie,
I think of, uh, as as, uh,
holding a sense of poetry as a long
tradition that reaches back to the origins
of our language. Uh, and is,
uh, alive with us today. Uh,
and that I'm writing about it,
writing it,
translating it are your
activities, uh, and uh, also,
uh, teaching it, uh, and, and Ray
is one of our best and, and, uh,
most revered teachers in the
history of this department.
So it's a really wonderful a
honor for me to get to, uh,
give the stage and the
microphone, uh, to Marie Bora.
Would you please welcome here?
[inaudible]
thank you Lani.
I'm getting over a virus so I hope
my voice won't be too scratchy.
I have some water to help.
I think of it as it's really
all the same thing. You know,
Beowulf going Chaucer,
Milton Wallace, Stevens,
it's all the same thing. Nope. Innocence.
I want to begin this morning with a little
poem that you may never have heard of
or read by Wallace Stevens
called [inaudible], g, U,
B, B, I n a, l. And if you have
the poems of Steven's here,
you can look at it. If you
want though, doesn't matter.
I'm going to tell you it,
that strange flower.
The Sun is just what you say.
Have it your way.
The world is ugly and the people are sad.
That tuft of jungle feathers,
that animal I is just what you say,
that savage of fire,
that seed have it your way.
The world is ugly and the people are sad.
In this poem,
the voice of the imagination and Stevens,
his concept of the imagination with the
Capitol lie speaks and it addresses a
you that views the world
without imagination.
That is you. The you have the
poem, you take the Sun for granted.
You aren't excited by seeing it,
by the thought of it,
by the fact that it has arisen on this
particular day and you hope it's going to
rise again tomorrow.
You don't feel as Stevens
puts it in another poem.
The Sun comes up like news from Africa
and that's how one with the imagination
at work fields about the sun imagination
as Stevens conceives of it is the
incessant stream of language emanating
from the human consciousness.
As we live expressing both the state of
the world at a given time and its own
state, both of which states
are constantly changing.
Our interstate changes.
Our inner weather changes as the outer
weather of the world changes and as the
seasons change.
The work of the imagination as represented
in Goulburn though is the generation
of metaphors.
The Sun is a strange flower,
a Tuft of jungle feathers,
an animal I a savage
of fire and to seed at.
One thing that's important about this
to notice is the rapidity with which one
metaphor it gives way to another metaphor.
You don't stick with one,
you don't have a
definitive one that has it.
You go on and if the poem were longer,
there'd be more metaphors.
Still the mind is in motion as
the world also is in motion.
Implicit in this poem also is Stevens's
particular concept of happiness without
the imagination.
The poem says the world is ugly and
the people are sad and we can turn this
statement on its head and say
with equal validity from Stevens,
his point of view with the imagination,
when the vital imagination
isn't residence at at work,
the world is splendid,
exciting and the people are happy.
Note that happiness has nothing to do
with personal fortune with the fact that
you've been accepted by Harvard medical
school or you perform brilliantly on the
basketball court or the football field
or got the date you're hoping to get.
Happiness is internal
independent self starting,
but also shared communal human.
The work of the imagination for Stevens
is the same as the writing of poetry,
the generation of poetry on a small
scale as in governor [inaudible] and many
other such or on a large mythical
scale as in the Aurora's of autumn,
a lot of Stevens,
his early poems are called by him.
Anecdotes. Now, an anecdote,
if you go back to the etymology of
the word is something unpublished.
It's like a draft and
what Steven's would do,
he lived in Hartford, is
you probably know, he worked
in a big insurance company.
It was very successful and
he would walk every morning.
It was a great walker from his home in
West Hartford to his office in downtown
Hartford.
As he walked,
he would write poems,
poems would come to him.
He splints said, I never like
anything that doesn't fly in at May,
through the window,
he'd get to the office,
he'd call his secretary and he dictate
the poems he had thought of on the way to
the office on separate sheets.
She would give him the poems,
he'd put them in a desk drawer,
and then about a month he'd go through
what was in the drawer and throw some of
them away and keep some,
and the ones he kept would go into
whatever book it was that he was writing.
Oh,
to have his wastebaskets is what I say.
I dare to think that Stevens would have
liked or at least approved of the idea
of the first stanza of a poem I wrote
many years ago when I was getting up early
enough in March to see the sun rise.
Black Rim pale dawn.
Now as to rolling drums,
son,
you're a great signal comes to bid me on,
but Stevens said at less
pretentiously and better,
he wrote the Sun.
That brave man comes through
bows that lie in. Wait,
that brave man.
I'm skipping a little fears of my bed.
Fears of life and fears of death runaway,
that brave men comes up from below
and walks without meditation.
That brave man. And if you can
think of the song as a brave man,
you're well into Stevens,
I think.
I'm sure Steven would have liked a
story that I'm about to tell you.
When I was teaching Stephens years ago
in among other poets in my course in 20th
century poetry,
I was walking on campus one day and I
ran into one of my students and we were
just reading Steven's then, and I said
to him, well, how are you? How goes it?
How are things? He said,
oh, I'm fine. Uh, he said,
all my friends are depressed.
But when I hear how depressed they are,
I look at them and I think,
have it your way.
The world is ugly and the people are sad.
And Stevens would have liked that
because Stevens said that strangely that
poetry should make us happy.
It should help to make us happy.
He also said,
and this is rather hard to swallow,
perhaps for someone who's been struggling
with the Aurora's of autumn or notes
toward a supreme fiction or
any of the other big ones,
people should enjoy poetry
the way a child enjoys snow,
and that is true. Well, in
reading, Steven's especially
reading the little poems,
I always say you shouldn't worry about
a poem you should read on and find one
that tickles you,
that that you like and make a mark there
and returned to that poem later and
read it again.
Though it's also important I
know to study Stephen's to study,
especially the large poems,
the big creations,
the Aurora's of autumn exists
in a sequence of seasonal poems,
large scale seasonal poems.
That Stevens road,
the earliest one and seasonal terms is
notes toward a supreme fiction and that
is a poem of the Spring
and if you read it,
you'll see a lot of things that are
associated with Spring and Connecticut.
You'll see the, forget me not in bloom
though. He calls it the Myo Sodas.
Not to be sentimental about it.
You'll hear about Forsythia,
you'll hear about yellow and
the blue sky, uh, and it,
it's a spring poem,
then comes credences of summer and
then comes the Aurora's of autumn.
Now these poems go chronologically,
seasonally,
but they also go chronologically
in Stevens, his own life.
He has older as he writes,
eats one of them.
And when he wrote the Aurora's of autumn,
he was in his seventies and this is the
first of the poems in which the idea of
death comes in dauntingly
the idea of human death.
Because one thing that autumn is,
is the season that procedures winter,
winter death,
the death of the landscape in New
England and ultimately the death of the
individual human being.
And that threat comes into the
poem and is faced in the poem.
Now I want to go back to
the beginning of the poem.
So if you have a copy of it,
you could look at the beginning
and go very quickly through a sigh
sections one through seven maybe.
And I'm,
cause I'm going to end by talking about
sections nine and 10 and then something
about section eight
in the poem,
we see the imagination.
It's work as the creator of myth.
This is always been true of human culture.
There have always been
great myths of the world,
the myth that the world rests on
a turtle or the myth of creation,
how the world was created or how the
animals first came and Steven's toys with
mythical creation. In the poem
in particular, in section one,
he writes three different myths,
which one of which succeeds to the
other in trustee Benzion fashion.
Because,
uh,
an essence of the world as
Steven stinks about it is change.
As I intimated earlier. Uh, it's hard
to imagine Stevens living anywhere,
but in a temperate climate
where there are seasons,
it's hard to think of him as living in
the tropics or and at Artica because he's
a man of the seasons
amount man of the weather.
He writes a lot about the weather.
One of his poems begins, lights out,
shades up, a look at the weather.
Let's see what the weather is tonight.
On this particular night
in the first section of
the Aurora's of autumn,
there are three different myths,
one of which succeeds to
another with equal validity.
They are three myths about serpents.
First we have but cosmic serpent,
the bottle is his head,
his air.
I'm reading from the beginning of
the section beneath his tip at night,
eyes open and six on us in every sky.
Clearly there he is talking about
the dawning of stars at night.
Eyes Open and fix on us in every sky.
So this is a huge cosmic
serpent that he is imagining.
He's imagining the heavens as
presided over by a great serpent,
which may well have something to do
with the Constellation named Drake Code.
DRSC Oh,
which is dragon or or snake.
Then we throw that one away and
Steven says, or is this another?
And or in Steven's always has to be
answered or responded to by saying,
yes, this is another one. Let's have
another one. We've just had one.
Let's throw that one out and
have another one. The stale, uh,
has to always to be thrown out.
So now we get a terrestrial
serpent on a huge scale.
This is where the serpent lives.
You could underline that at the beginning.
The poem, this is where the serpent
lives. Well that's in line one. Uh,
now we're in line seven. This is where
the serpent lives. This is his nest.
These fields,
these hills,
these tinted distances and the pines
above that along and beside the sea.
So here we have a serpent that is a trick,
terrestrial myth,
a myth of the whole encompassing
the whole landscape.
And finally at the,
almost at the end,
his meditations in the Ferns,
can you find that?
It's the next to last
tercet of that section.
His as clearly the serpents.
Meditation's his meditations in the ferns
when he moved so slightly to make sure
of sun made us no less as sure.
And here is a third serpent
and this is a local serpent,
a particular serpent,
a serpent,
visualized in sensory terms.
We saw in his head,
black beaded on the rock,
the flecked animal,
the morning,
the moving grass,
the Indian in his glade,
the Indians glade.
That is the native of the soil.
In this section we find one of the
great opposites and Steven's a great
oppositions between pairs,
a imagination and reality is of course
one or imagination with the capitol lie
versus imagination with a lower case I
and imagination that sort of produces
little fancies.
But here we have a strange opposition
which is rather idiosyncratic with
Steven's between abstraction,
not and not between the
abstract and the concrete,
but between the abstract
and the particular,
the local.
At with that very often
characteristically and Stevens,
there comes a flash of the sensory,
a detail of color.
Black beaded,
the black beaded head of the snake,
a particular glade in New England where
native Americans once lived the Indian
in his glade.
The recognition of that.
So this opening section of the poem
demonstrates the imagination at work as a
generator of myths and one myth succeeds
to another myth one there was the
cosmic serpent, the terrestrial
serpent and the local serpent,
the particular serpent,
the serpent that we see right
there on a particular day.
Now something happens that's
characteristically Steven's
Ian and occurs at the
beginning of section two.
And this is something that
not everyone agrees on,
but this is how I interpreted and what
I'm giving you is my interpretation of
the poem which you have to take for
better or for worse. For the moment,
farewell to an idea.
I take this to be the discarding of
an achieved idea and the moving onto
something else.
So what Steven's is saying farewell
to is the whole serpent mythology,
a cosmic tr,
terrestrial and old.
And from that we turned
to something different.
We turned to seasonal change,
the change from summer to autumn.
And another important Steve
Benzion opposition comes
into play in this section.
And that is the opposition
between whiteness and color
or as Stevens often calls
it candor. Candor, as you
may know, is whiteness.
Uh, and if we were true
to our Latin etymologies,
all candidates would wear white robes.
Of course I,
it's a little hard to imagine some
of the men of white robe at any rate,
candor is abstract quite.
He also uses the word
blank in this section.
The man who was walking turns blankly
on the sand in notes toward a supreme
fiction.
The poem begins with Whiteness and moves
from whiteness from that ever early
candour too.
It's late plural from the
abstract to the particular,
the multifarious plural here summer,
which is stale. It's
over. It has happened.
So now it's time to throw it out and
move on to something else. Namely autumn.
And the whiteness is
visualized as a landscape.
A cabin stands deserted on a beach and
as the sort of summer cabin that we all,
most of us probably know, a
white beach at a white cabin, uh,
probably, uh, white fence
and maybe a white, uh,
enclosure for a shower that you can
take after you've swum. It's summer.
The flowers against the wall or white
reminding of a white that was different,
something else last year or before.
And now the wind is beginning to blow.
Summer's over.
The wind is blowing the
sand across the floor here.
Being visible is being white
is being of the solid of white.
The accomplishment of an
extremist in an exercise,
the season changes. A cold
wind, chills the beach,
the long lines of it grow longer.
Emptier a darkness gathers though it does
not fall and the whiteness grows less
vivid on the wall again and again in the
Aurora's of autumn we have some sort of
reassuring or splendid or restful vision
and then come some sort of threat,
a cold wind.
Uh,
in one of the sections the wind knocks
like a rifle butt against the door.
Uh, and this poem was written
during the decade of World War II.
So violence,
death,
the coming of winter are linked implicitly
in the poem with the idea of war,
the death of war.
And then we go to a single man who was
always the vehicle of the imagination.
In the end,
the imagination has to reside in
the consciousness of the individual,
of each one of us.
Although from it we can project a great
cosmic imagination and unmoved mover or
a generator of, of images as
Stevens does later in the poem.
So here we have our hero,
the individual man,
the man imagining the man who was
walking turns blankly on the sand.
He observes how the north is always
enlarging the change with it's frigid
brilliances.
It's blue,
red sweeps and gusts
of great and killings.
It's polar green,
the color of fire and ice and solitude.
So here what happens is very much like
what happens to white light when it's put
through a prism and broken up
into the colors of the rainbow.
This is what happens in the beginning
of notes toward a supreme fiction,
and it's what happens here.
The whiteness of summer breaks up into
the prismatic colors of the Aurora's of
autumn. Now, you probably
have never seen them.
I've never seen the rowers of autumn,
but I happened to know
a man who was in ag,
Gail living on the old campus in the
early 1940s and he told me that he
remembered coming out of where he lived
at night onto the old campus and looking
up and seeing the Aurora
borealis in color.
It could happen then.
I've seen it in Maine in the summer sky,
but as I've seen it,
it's been quite and dark.
And what you see are white pulsations
in the sky. They're very beautiful.
They're very wonderful,
but it's been many,
many years since I saw any colors
in the auroras. Nonetheless,
this is what he's writing
about the Aurora borealis
in its colors.
Section three here again,
farewell to an idea,
a way with the cabin way with
the man walking on the sand.
Now we moved to something else and what
we moved to in the next few sections are
myths. Large scale myths. First,
the myth of the mother,
the earth mother,
let's say the sky mother,
the mother as nurturing,
as warm as tender,
the mother who could perhaps
be symbolized by summer,
by a Balmy beneficence,
summer day by the warmth
of the sun on a summer day.
Then we get the father,
the myth of the father,
and this is the kind of,
well,
let's say the Joe flight or
Zeus like being the, the uh,
uh, man who is in, who
presides over the heavens.
But first we have the mother.
The mother gives transparency
to their present piece.
She makes that gentler, that
congenital beat. But here again,
as in over and over.
As I said earlier in this poem,
the concept of something
warm, gentle, reassuring,
gives away to some sort of threat,
the coming of cold,
the wind darkness,
and finally the wind like a rifle.
But at the end of the poem,
boreal night,
I'm toward the end of section three here
will look like frost as it approaches
them and to the mother as she
falls asleep and as they say,
good night,
good night upstairs,
the windows will be lighted, not
the rooms. What does that mean?
That means that they've turned off the
lights and going to bed. Nonetheless,
there are lights appearing in
the windows and what can they be?
But the lights of the Aurora borealis
that shine in the windows of the house,
even though the light doesn't
come from within the house,
it comes from the heavens.
A wind will spread windy grandeur's
round and knock like a rifle butt against
the door. The wind will command
them with invincible sound.
So this is the temporary reassuring
togetherness. I hate that word,
but I can't avoid it.
Really in in this section,
this is where we were all together with
the mother and all was well and it was
summer, but this can't last.
It never lasts. Something more,
something less welcome takes his
place section for farewell to an idea.
Leave the mother behind, leave. We've
had her now we moved to the father.
The father's sits in space.
Wherever he sits of bleak regard,
he is not a warm nurturing
kind of presence. His regard,
his gaze is bleak and then we have this
curious image as one that is strong in
the bushes of his eyes. I think
that alludes to the word ambush. Uh,
he has a power that is held in
check as when someone is an ambush.
The strength is there
and is not yet let out.
Okay?
He says, no to know.
That's an affirmation.
He says yes to yes.
He says yes to know that as an
affirmation he always affirms,
he never denies and he affirms something
new and then something new and then
something new as signified
by in saying yes,
he says farewell.
That is when you accept
and affirm the new idea,
the new imaginative construction.
You have said farewell to the one that
preceded it as he is done earlier in the
poem, farewell to the idea of the cabin
for well to the idea of the mother,
he leaps from Heaven to
heaven more rapidly than bad
angels leap from Heaven to
Hell in flames. This is clearly
an illusion to the Christian myth.
And I'm going to bring up the Christian
myth later toward the end of what I'm
saying about,
about the poem you perhaps have read.
If you are English majors,
you may have read paradise lost.
So you've read about how the bad
angels leap from Heaven to Hell.
They're driven out by the
powers of God and his son. Um,
so the father leaps,
that is his imagination,
the cosmic imagination,
the large scale imagination that he
personifies is hugely vital and capable of
leaping from one concept to another
from one heaven to another one myth to
another.
No,
I meant to say a little earlier and I
will say that I think though I couldn't
substantiate it from this place alone,
that toward the end of section three,
the mother, she falls asleep. And
as they say, good night, good night.
I consider that one of a number of
illusions in the poem to the play Hamlet.
There are a lot of, uh, uh,
there's a lot of theater.
Theater is one of the motifs of the poem
and I haven't time to go into that in
detail,
but you see it again and again.
And one of the things that happens in the
poem is that a company of actors comes
as happens in hamlet and hamlet
welcomes them. And good night,
good night, good night. Sweet ladies.
Good night's sweet ladies. Good night,
good night. I think it
alludes to that, uh,
Elliot quotes that I think it's in the
wasteland that he, that he does it.
So the mask,
the masks,
the actors come and company.
Now I'm at section four toward
the end of that section,
the actors approach and company in
their masks. These are not human actors.
This is a super human drama
that is being played, uh,
and the father is inviting them.
And then there's a very eloquent in
vocation of the father as the master,
the master of the Maze,
master Oh master seated by the fire and
yet in space and motionless and yet of
motion the ever brightening
origin profound and yet the king.
And yet the crown.
Look at this present throne.
What company in masks can
choir it with the naked wind.
How can we celebrate?
How can there be a cell,
a theatrical celebration of the world
when the wind is blowing and autumn is
coming and darkness is coming,
uh,
to call the master the ever the
origin of motion motionless.
And yet the origin of motion is
to go back to concepts of God.
The divine as the unmoved mover applied
to the Christian God and sometimes to
other divinities.
So once again,
we have an illusion to religion,
which is nonetheless not part
of a religious presentation.
In section five,
the mother and the father give a party.
I don't happen to like
this section very much.
I don't think Steven's really
succeeds in jazzing it up. Uh,
the way he tries to,
the children laugh. The,
I don't like the,
the Negro buses who dance like curious
ripeness is of pattern and make insidious
tones clawing the sing
song of their instruments.
The children laugh and jangle attend
any time while he's trying very hard to
jazz it up. But for me it doesn't quite
work. Nonetheless. This is what it is.
This is the party that
the world stages for us,
that as we look out,
the party of spring are the party
of the colors of autumn leaves.
And it's kind of symbolic
representation of that.
The musicians strike the instinctive poem.
And so on this then is shatty Yom.
Do you find that that's three stances,
three tercets from the
end of that section? Uh,
I believe that [inaudible] is used here,
sorry as the name of a
great chateau in France,
there is such a chateau.
So it is uh, a palace,
a castle where there could be a
splendid party with dancers and with,
with music.
This then is shatter your as you please.
We stand in the tumult of the festival.
The world is a kind of tumultuous
festival at times that goes on around us.
Let's say on an autumn day when the trees
are very bright and color and the wind
is blowing and the sky is blue and the
leaves are drifting from the trees as the
two mode of a festival.
But all of a sudden what festival?
This loud disordered Mooch,
these brute like guests,
these musicians dubbing at a tragedy,
a dub dub, which is made up of this,
that there are no lines to speak.
There is no play or the person's
act one merely by being here.
So once again we have affirmation and
then comes threat than comes denial.
There really is no play.
There is no theater.
It's only something that we imagined.
But then immediately as if to prove
its validity and its vitality.
The great imagination speaks in section
six and others at the beginning of that
section.
One of the most eloquent tributes to
the beauty of the cosmos that I know in
poetry in which an amazing
telescoping of time takes place.
What do they call it?
Fast forward photography perhaps you've
seen one where the flower grows up and
is seen blooming and here we see geology
in fast forward we see mountains rising
and falling like water,
like waves.
It is a theater floating
through the clouds itself.
A cloud,
although of Mr did rock and mountains
running like water wave on wave through
waves of light.
It is a cloud to transform to cloud
transformed again idly the way a season
changes color to no end except the
lavishing of itself than change as light
changes yellow into gold and gold
to it's opal elements and fires.
Delight splashed wide wise because
it likes magnificence and the solemn
pleasures of magnificent space and then
human history is seen fast forwarding,
as the section goes on a up capital,
it may be as emerging
or has just collapsed.
Civilization has come to as a mountain
has come and has collapsed the day new
mall has to be postponed,
but now, once again,
the all importance of the hero,
the human hero,
that is the imagining mind is affirmed.
This is nothing until in a single man
contained nothing until this named thing
nameless is and is destroyed.
He opens the door of his house on flames.
That's the Aurora.
In other words,
the Aurora Borealis,
the scholar of one candle sees an Arctic
effulgence flaring on the frame of
everything he is and he feels afraid.
In section seven
Stephen's visualizes as a,
let's say a mythical hypothesis.
Suppose that there is a cosmic imagination
that imagines the whole show and
imagination that imagines the passing
of the seasons that imagines the earth,
the solar system, the whole cosmos.
Suppose that maybe there is.
Let's imagine that there is. So the
answer to the questions are always yes.
Is there an imagination that sits
enthroned as grim as it has been? Evolent,
the just and the unjust,
which in the midst of summer stops
to imagine winter. Yes, there is.
Why not when the leaves are dead,
does it take its place in
the north and unfold itself?
Goat leaper crystal than luminous
sitting in highest night here.
And I have no time to go into
this aspect of the poem. Uh, it's,
which is another one like the theater,
uh,
and then the hamlet illusions
that I think are there.
This is part of the astronomical motifs
in the poem and there's a great deal
about the stars. I mentioned Draco
and the First Section is possibly, uh,
underlying the celestial serpents.
A great big constellation
that is across the sky for us,
for us in New England.
And here the goat leaper is
the constellation Capricorn.
A Capricorn means goat horn as,
as you know,
and you may also know that Capricorn
begins in the Zodiac on the 22nd of
December,
which choose to say immediately
after the winter solstice.
So the Constellation Capricorn
take soap, comes in, uh,
at what Steven's at the end
of the poem calls in winters,
Nick in the nick of winter,
just as the solstice comes
and the Constellation
Capricorn becomes the dominant
constellation of the Zodiac.
Okay.
But now we can't stay solemn.
We have the mood has to change.
And so we get at the end of this section
a change from destiny to slight cap
priests with I think an
allusion to the word Capricorn.
And you may know that the Capri
element has to do with leaping.
Uh, so the, uh,
leaping from heaven to Hell
is associated with that.
It was changed from destiny,
dislike caprice,
and thus it's jetted tragedy.
It's steel and shape and
mournful making moved,
defined what must unmake it and what last,
what can say a flippant
communication under the move.
So all this is thrown away and what we
have so flippant, something flippant,
but that is the way Stevens,
his, uh, imagination works,
especially on a large scale
there.
Ares of autumn is not
architectonic Lee structured,
uh,
as say something like the odes of Keats
and Shelley are like at an alias or the
Ode on Melancholy or the
Ode on a Grecian Urn.
That is to say it does not move by
logical stages to a climax at the end.
That incorporates in is founded
on what has gone before.
Rather it is structured. If structure
is the word, as I've been telling you,
you go from one thing to another,
you go from one thing to its opposite,
you go from something solemn to something
flipping, you go from summer to autumn,
you go from day to night,
from the warmth of the mother to
the threat of death and darkness.
Nonetheless,
it does move.
The poem does move toward what
I would call a culmination,
not an architect tonic
or structural climax,
but a kind of emotional climax.
And this happens in the
next to last section,
section nine a and is predicated on the
assertion of innocence at the beginning
of section eight.
And I should say in case I don't have
time to do justice to it at the end,
uh, that in section 10, the
whole thing falls apart.
We discard the whole thing.
Uh,
and it all becomes fragmentary and
the musical creations become trivial.
Uh,
and we got an ending that is completely
unsatisfactory to those of us who love
resonant rhetorical endings.
It's just not like that.
And we can't look in Stevens
for that kind of ending.
The term innocence is another term like
imagination that has to be thought of in
it's Steve Benzion sense.
Cool.
The opposite of innocence or
Stevens is either guilt or malice.
Uh, now you probably know, you may,
you may know that the origin
of the word innocence,
the root Latin root of the word innocence
is a Latin verb meaning to harm.
No,
Kara.
So in no sense literally
is on harming nus.
The
of affirmation of innocence that comes
to the speaker in section eight arises in
a sense from all that is gone before.
That is from the myth making
of the early sections.
Because as we think back on them,
it's obvious that Stevens
is overarching myths,
is great. Cosmic myths,
the mother, the father,
the celestial imagination that imagines
the whole world and the passage of the
Zodiac.
Uh,
none of that has anything to do with
revealed religion or particularly with the
Christianity that we,
most of us know so much about.
As we think back,
it's obvious that there's nothing
in them about a benevolent God,
a God who watches over us,
a god who comforts us and who will
reward us if we were virtuous.
There's nothing about that.
The imagination with the capitalized,
the cosmic imagination is
as grim as it is benevolent.
The world is as grim as it is benevolent.
We have the benevolence of summer,
but always after it,
the darkening of autumn and the grimness
and cold of winter and humanly we have
the change from youth
to the midst of life,
to finally the coming of death and that
possibility that inevitability is faced
at the end of the poem.
So what is innocent here is the world.
The world is innocent.
It means us no harm.
It is not malicious.
It's if there's No God who
benevolently watches over us.
There's also no god who judges us
well who can signs us to damnation.
So we can live in the world in the
state of innocence without what Steven's
eloquently calls.
And I hope you'll check
it out again after this.
The enigma of the guilty dream.
Christianity,
we don't understand it. It's a riddle.
It's the guilty dream, but it's a dream.
Uh,
like all of the dreams
the world operates in personally,
it means us no harm.
Now I'm going to read toward
the end of section eight.
So then these lights,
these lights are the Aurora Borealis,
which he's referred to by the phrase
these lights several times in the poem.
These lights are not a spell of light,
a saying out of a cloud,
but innocence and innocence of the earth
and no fault sign or symbol of malice
that we partake thereof lie down like
children in this holiness as if awake we
lay in the quiet of sleep.
I haven't time to go on.
But in section nine,
Stephen's picks up on this and says we
were as Danes and Denmark all day long,
hail hearted, Lansman we were brothers.
And here we have the play hamlet again.
Uh,
as you remember in hamlet,
there's something rotten in the state
of Denmark and here the world is Denmark
and there's something wholesome
in the state of Denmark.
And what does wholesome is us and the
world and the beauty of the world,
even though that beauty eventually,
uh,
gives way to darkness and cold shall
we be found hanging in the trees next
spring.
This is toward the end of section nine.
And people interpret this differently
and I think the word hanging is
misleading,
but I read it as meaning are we going
to come back in the spring as the leaves
come back in the spring and we're not.
Human life is a single trajectory,
has a single spring,
summer and winter and loss
in such a world is permanent.
But in this world we have
the splendor of the world.
If we can simply see it,
if we can allow ourselves to see it
without preconceptions and we can see the
stars putting on their glittering belts.
And this reminds me of the
Constellation or Ryan, uh,
which has a glittering belt
and a dagger hanging from it.
They throw around their shoulders,
cloaks that flash like a great shadows,
last embellishment,
but now suddenly there's a change.
There's a drop in the rhetoric to
the utmost simplicity of language.
The last tercet three part three
line stanza of section nine.
It may come tomorrow in the simplest word,
almost as part of innocence almost
as the tenderest and the truest part.
And it,
I'm quite certain his death and hamlet
if speaks memorable and extremely simple
words.
When he is about to die,
he's about to fight a duel and which
is going to be poisoned. And Horatio,
his friend is concerned
and fears his death.
And hamlet says, Tosh, it's nothing. Uh,
if it be not today,
it will be tomorrow.
And who'd been out tomorrow? It will
be today. And if it'd be not now,
it will come. And that I think is
what is being echoed in a sense here.
It may come tomorrow.
And the simplest word,
this is almost as a part of innocence
almost as the tenderest at truest park.
Well, I can say only a few
words about section 10 as I say,
everything goes to hell. And section 10,
all the great concepts are discarded.
But in section 10,
we do return to the concept
of happiness in Steven's, uh,
we,
our humanity is and unhappy
people in a happy world.
That is to say we live in a world in
which there is splendor and vitality and
the sun is like a jungle tuft
of feathers and like an animal.
I,
but we're unhappy because we liked the
faculty of imagination as the EU does in
the poem,
the cosmic imagination
meditates the whole thing,
the history of humanity,
all of our fates.
And at the end of the
very end of the poem,
the mother reappears and
degraded form as a Harridan,
which means a kind of an ugly,
untidy old crone and a
haggling of wind and weather.
The splendors of the Aurora have
come to that buy these lights,
like a blaze of summary Straw in winters
snick and that's the last metaphor for
the Aurora borealis.
Winter's nick is the solstice,
the coming of con Capricorn,
the Constellation.
And the Auroras are like a blaze
of Straw in the midst of all that,
not a very grand image,
but for Stevens,
this is what we have.
And this is enough.
And I think in a poem
like the rowers of autumn,
he managed to convince us at least
temporarily, but it is enough.
Thank you.